que préféreriez vous avoir le brushing
de Dave le casier judiciaire de tapis
l'humour de Roucas ou la santé du pape
Daniel Prévost
êtes-vous favorable à la paix dans le
monde
oui bien sûr pourquoi pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
après une catastrophe atomique il ne
reste sur terre qu'un homme c'est vous
et trois femmes
laquelle choisissez-vous pour repeupler
la planète parmi attention
Martine Aubry
Michel Alliot-Marie ou Dominique Voynet
avec laquelle
décidez-vous de repeupler la planète
je pense pas que la planète est besoin
de se repeupler
si vous étiez le fils d'Alain Delon
est-ce que vous préféreriez être reconnu
par lui ou non
il faudrait d'abord que je sache qui est
Alain Delon
c'est très important
le brushing de Dave le casier judiciaire
de tapis l'humour de Roucas ou la santé
du pape
alors ça c'est vrai que c'est une
question vraiment nulle il y a pas mal
quand même est-ce que tu veux vraiment
que je réponde oui alors torture moi oui
pierre je ne répondrai pas à ça ça me
plaît pas du tout bien tu sais ça me
plaît vraiment pas
ça me dit rien j'ai pas envie tu vois
grosso modo comme ça
bon rêve ça va ça ne me gêne pas tapis
ça me gêne profondément et l'autre
comment il s'appelle rouquin
c'est comment tu l'appelles la santé du
pape faut pas toucher s'il te plaît
touche pas ce monsieur
[Musique]
Daniel Prévost
la bamb arrive dans 5 minutes que
faites-vous je la retarde
si vous deviez mourir dans un accident
d'avion est-ce que vous préférez que ce
soit un avion d'Air France de varigue ou
d'égyptair ah très bien Air France varie
ou égyptère
si vous deviez mourir dans un accident
d'avion celui où je pourrais m'envoyer
en l'air donc j'ai pas de tu vois je
n'ai pas de bon bien
est-ce que vous aimez les chiens avez
beaucoup beaucoup alors ah question
politique maintenant est-ce que vous
préféreriez un président de la
République d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout oui oh bien sûr c'était c'est une
question qui est totalement nulle
effectivement mais faut que je réponde
par une unité ça va être très dur pour
moi c'est dur de répondre
à qui accorderiez-vous le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des jeunes ou un
jeune qui tape sur des vieilles
c'est pas bien un vieux qui se tape des
jeunes
veulent moi je m'en fous je m'en fous
c'est pas un jeune qui tape sur des
vieilles
rater de tube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu